I bet you at one point you envisioned
yourself I could be present in the
United States and of course there's a
law if you're born outside the country
you can't be the president United States
doesn't matter that had to be a huge
frustration to you it really wasn't
because I felt kind of like everything
that I've accomplished in my life
if it's the bodybuilding career if it's
the movie career becoming Governor
setting up my Schwarzenegger Institute
all this stuff the millions of dollars
that they're made and everything all
because of America
and so would I why would I not complain
about the one thing I can't do
because it's really the only thing that
I can't do where someone says oh where
the law says no but everything else that
I was able to do happened and I was
because of America because they opened
this because no one was in a way no one
said you can't and so I'm not going to
complain about that I think that I would
have made a great president I think that
I have the energy and the will to bring
people together I think you would have
won I think you could have well of
course you think about it you're
absolutely right because so many people
come up to me and says oh I wish you
could be our president or something like
that so then of course you think about
it but I mean I do my things I do my
books I try to make life better for
people I like to kind of improve the
environment situation to make people
come together Democrats and Republicans
and to fight pollution to reduce
pollution worldwide and to protect our
democracy to make sure that people have
the right to vote everywhere in the
South or wherever it is does it kind of
the issues that I fight for and that I
feel really good about that I fight for
give something back to this country as I
said in my book you know tear down that
mirror which means stop looking at
yourself and look beyond that mirror and
see the millions of people that need
your help there's so many people out
there in America that need help and so I
think that we should all concentrate on
that and helping people that need help
and not just think about ourselves
foreign